muffin n'atteindra jamais ses 9 ans
sanglote charme entre honneurs le
désespoir de la mère de la petite
cédrika est infinie en fin de semaine
alors qu'elle se trouvait dans sa
voiture avec sa fille près d'un mémorial
en l'honneur d'un afro américain abattu
par la police d'atlanta il y à un mois
un groupe d'individus armés à tirer en
sa direction tuant la petite si correa
ce sont des gens de la communauté qui se
tirent dessus déplore la mairesse
d'atlanta assez c'est assez a dit elle
le même jour dans la capitale américaine
devon maintenir 11 ans est sorti de la
voiture pour aller chercher un chargeur
de téléphone chez sa tante et s'est
retrouvé au milieu d'une fusillade
il est mort sous les balles devant sa
famille je suis sans mots 17 voisine une
triste coïncidence pour son grand père
un membre de la communauté qui
travaillent depuis des décennies pour
prévenir le crime
ces gangs qui ont tué mon petit fils
n'ont aucune morale
cette violence meurtrière a aussi touché
l'alabama dans ce centre commercial où
une dispute entre saint côme a conduit à
des échanges de coups de feu
altergaz 8 ans étaient là au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment et il a
succombé à ses blessures
et que dire de chicago l'une des villes
les plus violentes des états unis les
morts se comptent par dizaines chaque
semaine et parmi eux des enfants
nathalie wallace sept ans est morte
d'une balle dans la tête alors qu'il
jouait dans le jardin la tenue dans ses
bras jusqu'à son dernier souffle
ces fusillades ne peuvent pas être la
norme dans notre ville explique ce
policier
wim hoste qui ballotte offenders ngo
langues
pour lui il faudrait garder ces violents
criminels en prison plus longtemps mais
là encore en pleine pandémie les
pénitenciers sont déjà saturées
distanciation sociale oblige
dans un pays où la violence est
alimentée entre autres par la culture
des armes à feu et les tensions raciales
la situation ne risque pas de changer de
sitôt la mère de sécurité intérieure
reste une des plus récentes victimes
innocentes
oui mais non ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada washington